bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi --quatre
rejoint leur du journal de la rédaction
sur téléfilm merci de nous rejoindre
voici les principaux titres de
l'actualité locale
inauguration ce matin à l'observatoire
de versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
de la plateforme d'intégration et de
test 10 pips elle doit permettre d'
intégrer et tester notamment des
équipements embarqués sur des satellites
ou des sondes interplanétaires pour
l'étude de l'espace et des planètes du
système solaire
son responsable jean luc maria sera
notamment l'invité de ce journal elle
les élèves du collège einstein de magny
les hameaux disqualifié lors de la
finale de course en cours qui se
disputait hier cette opération nationale
vise à familiariser les jeunes élèves
avec le monde de l'industrie et des
sciences en créant de petites voitures
de formule 1 seulement leur modèle a été
jugée non conforme et puis est la
maladie est de fabry un trouble
héréditaire méconnu causée par une
anomalie génétique l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
elle vient d'y consacrer à une
après-midi une summer school aujourd'hui
avec de nombreux spécialistes l'un
d'entre eux le professeur dominique
germain sera tout à l'heure en plateau
nous en parlions hier le défi nature
reprend ses droits comme chaque année à
l'île des loisirs attrape avant le
village qui sera ouvert pour le grand
public durant le week-end ce sont les
entreprises 150 qui s'affrontent en ce
moment même sur place michael et demi
d'euros à assister d'elodie moines
bonsoir michael vous êtes sur place
quelles sont les épreuves auxquelles se
livrent actuellement les compétiteurs
bonsoir
alors il ya il ya globalement trois
épreuves c'est à dire de la course du
vtt mais également du canoë kayak
il termine par du canoë kayak nous
sommes justement avec alice picot qui
est directrice des sports à 50 en libye
nava nous détailler précisément le
parcours alors en fait on a quatre
épreuves effectivement une première
épreuve
les coureurs partent pour de la course à
pied ensuite il enchaîne sur la course
d'orientation avec des parcours qui sont
différents en fonction des équipes pour
éviter que chacune se suivent
il enchaîne avec du relais vtt c'est à
dire que chacun des trois coureurs prend
le vtt chacun son tour pour faire le
même parcours et termine effectivement
part du canoë-kayak avant d'arriver au
ponton et de faire un petit sprint
d'environ 100 mètres et est ce que c'est
une épreuve physique alors c'est une
épreuve physique
maintenant c'est ce qu'on appelle un
format court en terme de raid c'est à
dire que les meilleurs met un peu plus
d'une heure pour faire la totalité du
parcours ça reste néanmoins relativement
accessible même si on n'a pas l'occasion
de s'entraîner régulièrement
et justement est-ce qu'il faut quand
même avoir un petit entraînement vous
dit pas forcément alors pas forcément ça
dépend de ce que vous pratiquez comme
sport ou si vous êtes vraiment
sédentaires on a de plus en plus des
équipes qui participent et qui justement
s'entraîne avant de participer
et puis vous avez un certain nombre de
participants qui ont l'habitude de
fréquenter des clubs et donc de
s'entraîner par ailleurs donc pour eux
c'est relativement facile ce qui est
intéressant sur ce genre d'épreuve c'est
justement de faire des équipes avec des
gens qui ont l'habitude et ceux qui
l'ont moins ça fait un petit building de
cohésion d'équipé entre salariés c'est
tout l'intérêt de l'épreuve mais
seulement l'objectif de l'épreuve c'est
vraiment créer une bonne ambiance entre
les entreprises exactement et entre les
salariés
c'est une épreuve qui est réservée
principalement aux entreprises qui sont
basés sur saint quentin en yvelines donc
aux salariés
l'idée également s'est proposé à ces
mêmes salariés de sortir un petit peu du
contexte du travail pour se rencontrer
pour se parler voire pour s'entraider
dans un cadre plutôt agréable et sur une
épreuve encore une fois qui est physique
mais qui ne l'est pas trop ça permet à
chacun d'y prendre un peu de plaisir
merci beaucoup à nice merci michael
depuis l'île des loisirs à trappes pour
le trophée des entreprises et vous
pouvez tomber la veste vu la chaleur
qu'il fait sur place le défi nature pour
le grand public en tout cas ce sera à
partir de samedi
innovation à présent une plateforme
technique ouverte à la communauté
scientifique mais aussi aux entreprises
une plateforme technique pour intégrer
et tester des équipements embarqués
destinés à étudier l'espace où la terre
la pit c'est son nom a été inauguré ce
matin dans les locaux de l'observatoire
de versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines
basé à guyancourt
visite guidée catherine château et
patrick jacques de dixmude
ce que vous voyez là est une cuve à vide
thermique pour les non-initiés cela ne
veut pas dire grand chose et pourtant
dans cette cuve on peut simuler à la
fois les conditions des prêts autre
atmosphère que ce soit au niveau spatial
ou martien un outil unique en france on
peut reconstituer quasi parfaitement
l'atmosphère qui règne sur mars et y
tester les futurs instruments spatiaux
qui partiront sur mars il y en a très
peu dans l'ombre qui peuvent simuler
l'atmosphère martienne
un peu plus loin ce que l'on appelle un
pot vibrant qui lui sert à tester les
différentes parties des 7 et 8 pour
vérifier lors de leur lancement dans
l'espace qu'ils supporteront bien les
vibrations
actuellement l'on peut voir en est c'est
une antenne pour un radar martien ici
des bouées instrumenté qui seront
déployés dans l'océan arctique
dans le cadre de l'étude du changement
climatique 25 seront assemblées sur site
là encore une autre innovation un mur
d'image immersif ce mur sert
actuellement à faire de la modélisation
3d du tracking avec des données qui
viennent de différents laboratoires en
ce moment l'étude d'interaction des
vents solaires sur le champs électro
magnétiques terrestres l'aspect 3d et le
tracking ça permet de s'immerger
vraiment dans un modèle quand on est un
écran un petit écran de pc de bureau ou
même d'ordinateur on n'a pas la notion
vraiment
on n'a pas le rendu au temps de rendu
que dans le réel là on est vraiment
c'est comme si on se baladait dans
l'espace et qu'on peut plonger à
l'intérieur ça donne vraiment une
nouvelle vision de la cheffe de la
modélisation et ça permet d'en déduire
beaucoup plus de choses un mur
interactif dédié aux chercheurs n'est
pas seulement les entreprises peuvent
également l'utiliser
c'est le cas de cette start-up
saint-quentinoise qui utilisent le
mirent dans un but de mise en scène
immobilière
là on peut modifier les couleurs le vert
donc je peux me déplacer
le mur est à disposition de n'importe
qui qui aimerait vraiment évidemment le
principal c'est scientifique
ici on peut faire des partenariats avec
des start up ou des entreprises
on est on est également portée à à faire
ce genre de choses
opéré une synergie entre le monde
scientifique et le monde industriel une
des possibilités de cette plate forme
d'intégration et de services mise donc à
la disposition de tous ça permet non pas
de faire de l'argent on reste une plate
forme académique mais ça nous permet de
limiter au mieux nos coûts de
fonctionnement qui sont importants pour
des infrastructures de cette ampleur là
la plateforme aura coûté 6 millions
d'euros financés par trois acteurs
majeurs la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le cnes et le conseil régional le
directeur technique de cette plateforme
intégration tests de l'ové est ce qu est
en plateau à présent bonsoir jean luc
maria ce mois est bienvenu on va tout
d'abord au situer les enjeux de cet
équipement en quoi ça va vous permettre
de mieux poursuivre vos missions les
missions de l'observatoire de
versailles-saint-quentin rappelle que
vous êtes spécialisé dans les sciences
de l'environnement du client du climat
et du développement durable si c'est ça
donc l'observatoire au travers ses
activités de recherche qui sont portées
par les laboratoires affiliés à cet
observatoire donc travailler sur des
thématiques notamment spatiale et
environnemental donc les laboratoires
font de l'instrumentation c'est à dire
des équipements qui sont ensuite
déployés soit sur terre pour l'étude de
la terre peuvent être embarqués sur des
ballons sous des ballons sur des avions
également et bien sûr sur des satellites
et des sondes interplanétaires
c'était l'inauguration ce matin avec
quelques démonstrations il ya des
applications concrètes des tests
grandeur nature
oui alors vous voyez tout à fait alors
certains alors aujourd'hui c'était
l'inauguration pour marquer la fin
officielle de l'installation de tous les
moyens c'est un projet qui date de
plusieurs années
aujourd'hui donc inauguration on a déjà
démarré l'opération de certains moyens
et va par exemple en début de semaine on
a testé l'antenne que vous avez vu sur
le pot vibrant et donc un morceau d'un
instrument qui doit se poser à la
surface de mars d'ici quelques années
donc ça a été testé
lundi et demain on teste un ce qu'on
appelle un anneau satellite donc un
petit satellite pour aller étudier les
hautes couches de l'atmosphère terrestre
et pourra être lancée par la cie qui
sera lancée l'année prochaine
projetée du concret c'est du concret je
parlais des enjeux tout à l'heure
justement ça va permettre aux chercheurs
aux étudiants d'être à la pointe aussi
sur un plan européen un plan mondial
aussi c'était oui tout à fait c'est donc
on est on est ouvert on une plate forme
académique est ouvert aux équipes
scientifiques techniques et du monde
étudiant bien évidemment donc on est là
en fait pour leur permettre d'accéder à
des moyens qui sont pas forcément
accessibles au niveau d'un seul
laboratoire
donc l'idée un vraiment de base de notre
infrastructure c'est une structure de
mutualisation à destination de tout le
monde académique qui pourrait utiliser
et donc pas seulement puisque
effectivement on est ouvert aussi aux
entreprises comme vous avez pu le voir
tout ça est assez unique
ces équipements qui sont proposés où je
faisais lire sur votre universal or il
ya deux cas il ya des moyens qui ne le
sont pas ou qui sont déjà disponibles
soit dans d'autres laboratoires de la
région ou en france d'autres par contre
sont tout à fait unique
la cuve à vide qui a été cité
effectivement à une fonctionnalité
particulière qui nous permet de simuler
l'atmosphère martienne et ça c'est tout
à fait unique en france et probablement
en europe et c'est ça qui est le plus
remarquable sur ce site les ce qui fait
la différence parle en fait non ce qui
est remarquable si la somme de tous les
moyens qu'on a
qui nous permettent aussi bien de
travailler sur des instruments pour la
terre que pour l'espace et de s'ouvrir
aujourd'hui de nous ouvrir aujourd'hui
au monde et au tissu économique local de
saint quentin
on peut peut-être un peu insister
justement sur l'aspect ouverture aux
envies de prise parce qu'il ya une vraie
synergie qui va se faire un café le
bassin local et toutes ces entreprises
qui m'était gravitent autour voilà donc
dans notre mode de fonctionnement on est
aussi bien ouvert effectivement aux
équipes académiques coentreprise on est
dans une phase effectivement démarrage
opérationnel donc on est en cherche
aujourd'hui effectivement à attirer à
intéresser des entreprises du tissu
économique local
d'abord dans un premier temps est
effectivement l'exemple là qui a été
donné c'est une start up de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sky one portal
qui vit qui on s'est rencontrées de
façon tout à fait opportune lors d'un
salon spécialisé on a découvert qu'on
habitait au même endroit et on a proposé
dans le cadre de cette inauguration de
faire une démonstration à deux et ce qui
a très bien marché alors c'était même un
peu plus que deux puisque c'est avec le
groupe bouygues construction est
également implanté ici on a pu faire une
démonstration de ce qu'on appelle le
home-staging de la visite d'appartement
virtuel où on peu avant d'avoir son
appartement visiter son appartement
choisir les caractéristiques du mobilier
l'agencement des sims grandeur nature
exactement
les entreprises qui vont payer aussi
donc ça permet un certain
autofinancement que ça wily long la mi
lourds investissements au départ mais il
faut aussi après il est tout à fait
alors quoi comme je le mentionnais dans
l'interview ce matin effectivement
toutes ces infrastructures coûtent
beaucoup d'argent à faire fonctionner
donc en fait on demande une
participation financière bien évidemment
que ce soit des entreprises ou des
entrevues des équipes public également
qu'ils utilisent simplement pour limiter
effectivement nos coûts de
fonctionnement qui sont qui sont
importants il va falloir trouver un
équilibre entre les universitaires les
chercheurs les entreprises qui vont
vouloir l'utilité est déjà un calendrier
précis enroulement l'année ils demandent
comment ça va fonctionner alors on est
en phase de démarrage à des moyens qui
commence à être bien
bien chargé effectivement donc le jour
on va vraiment se poser ces questions ce
sera bon signe c'est que ça fonctionnera
grâce aux activités alors cela dit le
choix en fait 2 du plan de charge est
conditionnée par une demande que l'on
fait à ce qu'on appelle un comité de
suivi qui s'est organisée autour cette
plateforme où chacune des tutelles
partenaires de cette plateforme est
représenté on peut imaginer que le jour
où il ya un télescopage entre deux
projets c'est ce comité qui prendront la
décision de savoir si on privilégie l'un
plutôt que l'autre pour la suite du
journal tout à l'heure nous recevrons un
d un des responsables des enseignants du
cycle médical de l'université de
versailles saint-quentin-en-yvelines que
vous avez croisé en loge je vous entends
des échanges est ce qu il souhaitait
aussi c'est qu'il ya un échange entre
les disciplines et que pourquoi pas le
pôle santé viennent de temps en temps à
travers 50 ans ni ville de montigny à
lui en cours pour venir vous voir
oui alors fi dimension c'est
effectivement rencontré juste avant le
plateau l'intérêt aussi pour nous c'est
que nos moyens peuvent aussi servir à
d'autres thématiques que le spatial que
l'environnement est typiquement notre
mur d'image peut tout à fait être
utilisé à des thématiques du domaine de
la santé on a déjà des applications où
on a des équipes parisiennes qui
viennent simuler des molécules en trois
dimensions et effectivement il ya
probablement une très forte synergie a à
voir avec les équipes même de
l'université de versailles dans le
domaine de la santé
merci jean luc marie brizard de la
plateforme à d'autres tegra sion les
tests de l'observatoire de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines cette
plateforme il sera il en sera également
question dans le prochain numéro de fil
échos ce jeudi soir sur notre antenne
merci à vous titiller innovation
toujours dans le journal un défi
technique avec la finale nationale de
course en cours hier les collégiens les
lycéens de toute la france se sont
réunis à l'occasion de cette opération
qui vise à familiariser les jeunes
élèves avec le monde de l'industrie et
des sciences pour représenter notre
département l'établissement albert
einstein de manille et les hameaux qui
avait triomphé lors de la finale
régionale
seulement leur mini bolides électriques
a été jugée non conforme après
l'euphorie c est la déception le
reportage
il est 14h30 c'est lors de la soutenance
devant le jury et point sur l'économie
vigie
ce que l'on m'a donnée c'est la
conception voiture la fabrication de
votre projet c'est dire comment
devient-on sangles et nego conception il
dispose de huit minutes pas une de plus
pour expliquer au mieux leur projet en y
intégrant peu d'anglais au collège
répartition des rôles conception de la
voiture thème de l'équipe lémanique aux
attentes de faire bonne figure devant un
jury quelque peu déstabilisant les
questions sur la fabrication de la
voiture ils ne les avaient pas prévu
pour vendredi
on a eu un roulement à bille don quelle
est la particularité de ces roulements à
bille c'est que c'est des cages vides on
nous a permis de faire mon défaut sur
les nouveaux rentrants fassions choisir
les éléments et créer man stand est ce
qu'on voulait qui apparaisent qu'on se
mettait d'accord sur des choses ont
cherché sur internet pour les trouver
c'était un peu de l'improvisation sur le
point on a c'était des questions qu'on
avait pas tellement acteur johnny allait
poser d'autres questions à la finale
régionale s'est plutôt bien passé on a
pu montrer tout ce qu'on voulait on a pu
montrer notre engouement pour ce projet
montré qu'on était vous avez fait ça en
plus qu'on avait vraiment aimé seront là
effet on a pu aussi exposé tout ce qu'on
avait fait la journée n'est pas terminée
un jury vient évaluer le stand de
l'autre équipe béninoise
toute l'année ils ont travaillé
d'arrache-pied pour arriver jusqu'ici en
finale nationale course en cours vise à
familiariser les jeunes élèves avec le
monde de l'industrie y ait des sciences
toutes les équipes ont fabriqué des
minis bolides électriques selon des
critères bien précis utilisé dans le
monde professionnel
17h bientôt l'heure des cas où les
courses de vitesse éliminatoires les
fruits métal roquettes cherchent leurs
horaires de passage introuvable sur le
tableau le couperet tombe alors que
l'équipe 23 fullmetal roquettes a été
déclarée non conforme
en fait et donc elle ne pourra pas
participer à la dernière épreuve de la
journée quelle épreuve du chaos qui est
une épreuve par élimination directe
malheureusement elles n'ont pas respecté
la largeur minimale des roues avant
qu'ils aient réglé à 26 mm sur la fiche
de conformité et leurs roues avant et
est à 10,9 mm donc c'est une petite
erreur qui va leur coûter voilà la
possibilité de participer au chaos
une mésaventure qui n'ont pas connu au
concours régional car ils ont depuis
modifié leur voiture pour tenter de
l'améliorer leurs chances de gagner la
fina s'effondre ils comprennent cette
décision mais la déception au diable la
crise et une défaite ont peur des roues
pour quelques millimètres à une roue
c'est dommage mais bon je veux dire qu
on est étonné d'y arriver jusque là donc
c'est une défaite dans la victoire je
vois comment dire mais on était une
équipe soudée on a appris plein de
choses on a on a découvert des métiers
des logiciels tard et c'est dans nos
coeurs et dans nos esprits longtemps ils
ne sont pas sur le podium mais quoi
qu'il en soit cette expérience est plus
que positive et sans y avoir suscité
quelques vocations santerre présent pour
la suite de ce journal avec ce colloque
cette summer school européenne autour de
la maladie et génétique de fabry la
faculté des sciences de la santé de l'ue
est ce qui vient de se pencher sur la
question cet après-midi bonsoir
dominique germainmont soit vous êtes
professeur des universités praticien
hospitalier l'un des spécialistes de
cette maladie génétique rare qui au
final ne touche qu'une personne sur un
peu plus de 110000 alors c'était les
chiffres historiques effectivement qu'on
peut trouver dans les traités de
médecine
les données les plus récentes qui sont
intéressés à chercher les nouveau nés
dans les maternités
par exemple un travail en italie un
travail à taïwan trouve une fréquence
beaucoup plus importante de l'ordre de 1
pour trois mille naissances dont on
découvre progressivement l'ampleur de
cette maladie je n'ai absolument il y
avait des cas autrefois cash est
manifestement dans la population
générale commencent à se caractérise
justement quels sont les symptômes
alors la fabrique c'est un magnifique
exemple de ce qu'on appelle une maladie
multi systémique c'est-à-dire qu'elles
touchent tous les tous les organes donc
il ya eu d'importantes atteintes rénales
le coeur le système nerveux central
c'est-à-dire le cerveau mais aussi la
peau les yeux les oreilles
donc ça veut dire que la vie du patient
est menacée lorsqu'on est atteint de la
visitation est très menacé c'est une
maladie qui est génétique et qui est
porté sur le chromosome x
on a donc une différence entre les
hommes et les femmes sont du coup
forcément plus concernés absolument on
considère que l'espérance de vie est
réduite d'environ une dizaine d'années
chez les femmes et là encore les données
hystérie historique retrouvé environ 30
ans de réductions d'espérance de vie
chez les hommes avec un décès à l'âge
moyen de 41
elle est difficile à diagnostiquer
justement quels sont les tests qui
permettent elle est relativement
sournoise et pernicieuse et j'ai
l'habitude d'écrire que tout enfant avec
par exemple des douleurs des extrémités
des des mains des pieds devrait être
considéré pour cette maladie mais on
doit aussi l'envisager devant dédia
thèse des pathologies beaucoup plus
communes comme par exemple l'accident
vasculaire cérébral
sarkozy me regarde la progression vers
la dialyse ou la transplantation est là
vous parlez des diagnostics qui se font
maintenant plus fréquemment vous parler
du nombre de cas plus nombreux ça veut
dire que des traitements qui sont
possibles si on le détecte rapidement
absolument donc c'est un des succès
essentielle de notre unité de recherche
nous avons développé il ya maintenant
légèrement plus d'une dizaine d'années
une thérapie enzymatique donc on est un
échelon en dessous de la thérapie
génique c'est à dire qu'on apporte aux
malades
la protéine l'enzyme qui lui fait défaut
pour ceux qui n'ont pas été détecté lors
de lors de la naissance comme c'est le
cas maintenant grâce aux progrès de la
recherche quels sont les signes qui
doivent alerter
alors on a des signes dermatologiques
qui consiste en des petites pas plus
rouges sur la peau mais comme je le
précisais auparavant les douleurs des
extrémités chez l'enfant tout accident
vasculaire cérébral un infarctus du
myocarde une atteinte rénale sévère une
surdité peut faire considérer cette
manette juste pour revenir sur le
traitement traitement veut pas dire
forcément guérison
c'est alors une maladie génétique nous
venons avec l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de publier nos
résultats il ya seulement deux semaines
dans le prestigieux journal of medical
genetics et un journal anglais de la
spécialité
ces travaux ont porté sur dix ans de
thérapie et donc j'ai vraiment plaisir
d'annoncer ce soir que sur les 52
malades initialement inclus nous avons
49 patients survivants alors que comme
je voulais dit précédemment le décès
survenaient auparavant un âge moyen de
41 ans et la moyenne de notre corps de
passion et de 47 ans il ya eu un
colloque cet après-midi j'imagine que
vous avez présenté ses différents
travaux qu'elle était un petit peu
l'objectif de montrer c'est un état des
lieux où il ya eu un échange avec vos
homologues à travers toute l'europe qui
aussi cherchent de l'ordre de leur côté
progresse donc la maladie de fabry comme
vous l'avez très bien dit est une
maladie rare
c'est important de diffuser la
connaissance est une des missions du
centre de référence de maladie rare que
je dirige et donc on a créé ce qu'on
appelle une summer school c'est à dire
une école d'été qui s'adresse à des
médecins déjà diplômés déjà qualifiés la
première édition a eu lieu à
l'université de versailles l'an dernier
avec c'était
une fois un début et donc nous avions
une trentaine de participants il ya eu
beaucoup de succès nous allons doubler
le nombre d'enregistrements cette année
avec 60 participants de l'europe entière
comme vous l'avez dit même m trois
médecins du japon des médecins russes
des médecins des émirats arabes unis
donc c'est un franc succès donc c'est un
franc succès français et saint
quentinois l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin notamment sur
les recherches que vous menez il ya un
centre de référence pour cette maladie
généraux c'est ça alors que le corps
d'un coordinateur
absolument j'ai un petit laboratoire de
recherche ici à montigny dans l'équipe
dirigée par luis garcia qui est une
équipe qui se consacre au développement
de nouveaux médicaments et de
biothérapie précisément pour ces
maladies rares
et puis un service de maladies
génétiques est basée à l'hôpital raymond
poincaré à garches avec le centre de
référence
labellisé par le ministère pour cette
maladie et une aide pour la prise en
charge signe pour accompagner oui le
ministère n'a santé joue très bien son
rôle puisque dans le cadre du plan
national maladies rares nous sommes
soutenus en termes de postes médicaux et
paramédicaux parce qu'on parle souvent
des difficultés de recherche autour des
maladies rares vous ne direz pas vous la
sonnette d'alarmé pour vous les choses
progressent avance correctement
on avait l'habitude de parler de
maladies orphelines autrefois et je
crois que un certain nombre de ministres
et d'hommes politiques ont pris
conscience de la gravité de la situation
ont mis en place ce plan national
maladies rares qui je crois est un
soutien important effectivement pour la
recherche et le soins pour les patients
atteints de cette date et les résultats
qui arrivent puisque vous nous l'avez
dit d une quinzaine de jours les bons
résultats vous avez pu communiquer merci
professeur mercier verdun vite s'il est
repassé sur ce plateau spécialiste donc
de cette maladie génétique rare la
maladie de fabry
le journal se poursuit à présent sur les
routes du département le cyclotour 78
s'achève ce jeudi après quatre jours à
parcourir les yvelines pour sensibiliser
aux violences sexuelles en république
démocratique du congo les participants
vont se retrouver dans la soirée à
versailles pour une conférence débat
c'est à l'initiative d'une association
humanitaire chrétienne un chiffre pour
mieux comprendre ce problème plus de 200
mille femmes ont été victimes de viols
de mutilations comme arme de guerre
depuis 1996 mais quel ennemi d'euros et
le dis moi une marche de 100 km à
travers les yvelines en quatre jours un
pari fou imaginé par l'association la
gerbe
c'est
opération baptisée cyclotour 78
consistait à relier à pied la commune
dès que via versailles en passant par
saint quentin en yvelines
objectif de ce périple dénoncer les
violences sexuelles faites aux femmes au
congo
on estime que depuis 1996 avec le début
des conflits d'instabilité du pays
il ya eu plus de 200 mille femmes qui
ont été violées donc viol comme arme de
guerre c'est systématique ses pensées et
volontairement pour déstructurer les
familles déstructurées des villages tout
est fait au vu et au su de tous
volontairement ces marcheurs ont poussé
symboliquement à vélo en hommage aux
bénévoles de l'association présent
d'afrique
ces derniers transports des lits
médicalisés dans tout pays pour les
interventions chirurgicales au total une
dizaine de personnes a participé à
l'intégralité de ce périple
cette marche nous demandent des efforts
mais on n'a rien sans rien il faut il ya
un prix à tout et donc il ya le coût de
l'effort mais aussi le plaisir de la
cause qu'on défend le plaisir d'être
aussi avec des personnes qui sont
motivés qui comprennent le sens de tout
ce que l'on fait donc voilà on est
très volontaire ça demande des efforts
puissent connais pas du tout des
marcheurs on n'a jamais jusque là donc
on marchera peut-être plus après ça
donne envie en tout cas le cyclotour 78
s'achève ce jeudi au conseil
départemental des yvelines à versailles
si vous n'avez pas marcher aux côtés des
bénévoles pendant cette opération vous
pouvez faire un don sur leur site
internet
cet argent permettra de financer des
interventions chirurgicales en afrique
avant de refermer ce journal des images
de saint cyr l'école et ses agents
municipaux en grève cet après-midi deux
heures de mouvements de protestation à
l'appel de la cgt rassemblés devant la
mairie ils se sont ensuite dirigés vers
la gare pour se faire entendre
l'objet de cette colère des aventis
mende échelons ralenti des heures
supplémentaires non payées en totalité
est de la butte précarité ou encore un
manque de moyens humains sur le terrain
c'est ce qui le dénoncent ils se sont
rassemblés devant la mairie avant de
partir donc ensemble vers la gare voilà
tous les agents de la collectivité sont
mécontents du à nos conditions de
travail
ça fait en deux trois ans on a eu trois
directeurs généraux
donc cela change assez fréquemment et
donc forcément nous devons avoir des
nouvelles directives qui nous demande
d'autant plus de travail et de
travailler dans l'urgence nous étions
dans la concertation
nous espérons que cela va continuer dans
un communiqué la municipalité répond à
ces revendications et tente d'expliquer
ses choix elle parle notamment de
pressions financières que le
gouvernement fait peser sur les communes
et de ses efforts en tant que mairie
pour assurer au personnel municipal des
conditions de travail malgré tout
favorable
rendez vous demain pour le journal du
vendredi présentée par catherine mulato
l'essentiel de l'actualité du jour le
résumé de la semaine tout de suite file
echo toujours préparée et présentée par
florane parfait très bonne soirée